a lot of people are using hand gestures
like the thumbs up sign
ronnie here is going to help me explain
if you use the thumbs up gesture
who do you support thumbs up gesture
means your m7 you support your m7
presidential room seven
okay thumbs up for president museveni
yes
do you have to be careful about using
the thumbs up yeah in some cities you
have to be careful
okay yeah what about bobby wine bobby
wine to have this gesture
bobby wine he's the major opposition
leader yes you use you use this sign
okay
and when you do it people know oh that
is bobby wayne
that is people power that's people power
with with the with the fist with a face
yeah just a
you check it i see are there any other
parties that you'd use
yeah there is a forum for democratic
change okay they use this sign with a
slight tear
not piece like this but it's light so
it's um
it's a take on the peace symbol it's yes
yes it is
it is and that is headed by uh patrick
amariat
okay uh foreign for democratic change is
one of the biggest it's actually the
biggest
opposition party in parliament okay so
they're a big deal yeah they're a big
deal and if you support them
it's like the peace symbol slide two
yeah
then you're there yeah then you're there
and then you're there yeah okay
understood so if you're into ugandan
politics
you gotta know your posters you've gotta
know your hand gestures as well